Hi.
My name is Marc Wandschneider,
and I'm a software engineer
here at Google.
I'd like to take a moment
to talk to you today
about using the Nearby
Messages API and beacons.
Nearby Messages is a new
API that enables your device
to react to nearby objects
and microlocations,
such as bus stops,
train platforms,
or even indoor locations
such as exhibits in a museum.
It makes use of a whole
host of technologies,
including Wi-Fi,
Bluetooth, audio,
and most interestingly
for us today,
Bluetooth beacons
powered by Eddystone.
Now, for more information on
the whole beacon platform,
check out our video
Developing with Beacons.
However, here are a
few quick reminders.
This is a beacon, as is
this, as is this, this,
and all of these.
In the most simple
of terms, beacons
are little Bluetooth
Low Energy, or BLE,
devices that sit around yelling
loudly-- well, if radio waves
could yell-- that they're here.
And that's it.
There's just this little
guy saying I'm beacon 12345,
and this one saying
I'm beacon 54321.
There's typically a
little battery in them,
and they'll broadcast that
information one to ten times
a second.
Now your mobile phone,
or tablet, or laptop,
if it chooses, can
scan for these devices
and use whatever it knows about
those beacons when it sees one.
And that's the catch.
Beacon 12345 isn't necessarily
super interesting by itself.
It's far more interesting,
or far more useful,
if I know that beacon 12345 is
sitting on my desk in London
on Buckingham Palace road.
But BLE devices can't
really communicate
that much information.
Again, all they can really do
is say, hi, I'm beacon 246810.
To get past this, we have to
register some data to associate
or store with this beacon
so that when we see it,
we can fetch the data
associated with it
and use it for whatever we want,
like identifying our bus stop.
Not unexpectedly, since I'm
up here recording this video,
we have a solution
that does exactly
this: the Nearby Messages API.
Once it sees a
beacon and determines
that it's one of yours, it
will fetch the data for it
and return that
information to your app.
Let's look at how that works.
First, we have a beacon sitting
around announcing its presence
to, well, anybody
who's listening.
Next you walk past with your
mobile device running an app
using Nearby Messages,
and it sees that beacon.
Nearby Messages then
goes to the server
to see if it knows
about that beacon,
and any information about
that is returned to your app.
If the beacon is
one you know about,
the app can start to
use that information.
Getting started with
the Nearby Messages API
and your beacons does
have a few steps,
but fortunately they're
all pretty straightforward.
So we'll walk through those now.
First, you need some beacons.
Eddystone is an open
format, and anybody
can support in their
beacon hardware,
so you have lots of choices when
you choose from whom to buy.
Make sure the ones
you're purchasing
support the Eddystone format
for maximal interoperability.
And then you can
work with a vendor
to address other things,
like battery life, weather
conditions, and
broadcast frequency.
Second, provision and
register the beacons.
This will be a combination
of using the beacon
vendors provisioning
applications to activate
the beacon and configure
just how often it broadcasts
and at what signal strength.
And then you'll need to register
some data with the Proximity
Beacon API for that beacon.
This register data is
what the Nearby Messages
API will return to you when
it sees one of your beacons.
To help you use the Proximity
Beacon API to register data
for your beacons, there's a
website with documentation
as well as a GitHub
repository with a sample app
to show you how it's done.
Finally, you integrate
the Nearby Messages API
into your application to start
looking for those beacons
that you provisioned
and registered.
This is known as subscribing
to messages for those beacons.
So on Android you'll set up the
subscription for those messages
by using the
message filter class
and adding Eddystone
device filters.
This message filter forms part
of your subscription options
that you then pass to
nearby .messages .subscribe.
For iOS it's going
to be quite similar.
You'll be working with a DNS
strategy object and telling it
you want beacon messages.
And then you set up the
subscription to those messages.
But really, rather
than bore you to death
here with screenshots
of IDEs, and websites,
and documentation,
and code, I'm going
to point you at the
excellent Getting Started
page, along with samples
and other documentation,
for the Nearby Messages API.
Using Nearby Messages
together with beacons
allows you to open up a
whole new world of context
sensitivity in your apps.
Let's take a quick
look at some of places
you can go for more
information about what
I've talked about today.
For information
on using beacons,
such as Eddystones
in general, visit
developers.google.com/beacons.
For nearby and the
Nearby Messages API,
visit
developers.android.com/nearby
and developers.andro
id.com/nearby/messages.
Now, for the registering data
part of working with beacons,
you'll use the Proxy Beacon
API, and you can get more
information at developers.googl
e.com/beacons/proximity as well
as checking out our
GitHub repository
at github.com/google/eddystone.
We've got a bunch
of sample apps there
that have both iOS and Android
versions for maximal choice
and will hopefully
get you started
doing a lot of cool things.
So I hope this
video has helped you
learn how to go about
using the Nearby Messages
API, along with your
beacons, and pointed you
in the right direction.
I certainly had fun making it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]